pete yes you look amazing thank you you
look handsome you look hot thank you she
didn't let me wear my propeller hat but
it's fine kim kardashian gushing about
boyfriend pete davidson as they make
their met gala red carpet debut he's
just super genuine all eyes were on the
couple as they made their way into
fashion's biggest night
and while speaking with her friend lala
anthony who was hosting the vogue live
stream kim sent all the praise to her
beau who to no surprise had some jokes
it doesn't piece
this is my brother pete
has new hair products
rice bacon comes from rice it grows your
hair back
pee yes you look amazing thank you you
look handsome you look hot thank you she
didn't let me wear my propeller hat but
it's fine yeah we're glad pete opted for
this look sporting a black suit and tie
with a white shirt as for kim she took
the theme of gilded glamour and white
tie literally stunning in one of marilyn
monroe's most iconic looks yes well this
is marilyn monroe's dress
and it's 60 years old and she wore this
when
she sang happy birthday to president
john f kennedy in 1962. um i had this
idea to to put it on and try it on and
then
they came with like armed guards and
gloves and
i tried it on it didn't fit me and so i
looked at them and i said give me like
three weeks and i i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to
be able to fit this but i it was such a
challenge it was like a roll right i was
determined but now that kim reached her
goal she says it's time for a reward
since i haven't eaten carbs or sugar in
about three weeks we're eating pizza and
donut party back at the hotel and they
did just that okay guys so after the met
i am starving
and my favorite donuts in the entire
world new york city are these mini
donuts
oh my god you guys i have them in the
room how cute is this
and pizza just days before the gala kim
and pete went red carpet official
the pair stepped out for the white house
correspondents dinner on saturday both
bringing their fashion a game kim
sparkling and balenciaga and pete
looking dapper in prada it seems things
are going well for the couple since
sparking things up back in october
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him he's just super
genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing
[Music]